hi and welcome everybody my name is
travis and like like uh in russia said
i'm going to be talking about
openstreetmap data um just a really
quick show of hands who out here has
heard of openstreetmap
great so openstreetmap is very popular
project and i'm really happy that you're
here to learn about it with me today
cool so what exactly we're going to
cover well first off we're going to talk
about openstreetmap
kind of the community surrounding it and
get into the what the data types are how
it's structured and how you can kind of
filter it and search through it
after this we're going to talk about
postgresql and how to work with
geographic data in postgresql
specifically focusing on the postgis
plugin and then we'll talk about how you
get openstreetmap data into postgres and
at the very end of the talk we're going
to talk about
how you structure
analysis projects with python and
that'll be the most fun part of the talk
because obviously we're at pycon
conference so cool
so why am i giving this presentation um
so the idea for this talk started last
year when i was doing research for my
master thesis project
and in my master's thesis project i was
doing an analysis of walkability in the
city of kiel germany
and to do this i used a lot of osm data
and to kind of help keep myself
structured and organized i needed a
process i needed a kind of a way to keep
the madness in order and
basically this is what i came up with
and i'm really happy to share with you
today
and just a little bit more about who i
am and where you can find me so first
off i have a website travishattheway.com
i just want to let everybody know that
you can go there after this talk to kind
of see a blog article that is basically
the mega tutorial that is this speech so
everything i say here you'll be able to
find there
you can also find the example code that
i use in this presentation on github you
find all the other stuff i do on github
and if you want to get in touch with me
you can
send me a message on linkedin and then
finally
if you want to hear all the kind of
weird bad music i write and make you can
go to soundcloud
so i always like to use
get an opportunity to present that and
then who am i yeah i'm above all i'm a
python program uh programmer but also
too i'm a just gis enthusiast i've never
actually worked as a professional kind
of gis practitioner so to say i've
always been a software engineer but i've
always really done this as a hobby
i'm also a social science scientist i
actually just recently completed a
master's degree in
the program was called sustainability
society in the environment and it was
really fun to kind of use my software
skills to figure out how to kind of
tackle um social issues and then last
i'm a guitarist and a musician very
amateur though
cool
and so who are you and who is this talk
for basically this talk is for anybody
who has an interest in both python
postgresql gis and especially you enjoy
messing around with data
the openstreetmap database is enormous
very very big and there's lots of really
cool stuff going on there it's growing
all the time so cool
all right
so let's kind of dive head first into
openstreetmap um talk about what it is
so what is openstreetmap is actually a
huge community and not only is it a
community but it's a community of
communities so all around the world you
have local chapters that are all
dedicated to basically mapping out their
communities and making this data open
source and freely available to everyone
to use
so
the contributors include individuals
just like you and i
but also public and private
organizations as well as local state and
national governments and if you go to
the wikipedia page
the list of contributors is actually
mind-blowing it's so big
okay so enough about the project itself
um
let's get into the data types so in osm
um openstreetmap there are primarily
three different data types we have nodes
ways and relations let's get into each
so first off a node
think of it a node as a point it's a
point with a geographical space that has
latitude longitude and node id um and so
some common examples of what these
things are include things like park
benches wastebaskets toilets anything
that's just a simple xy coordinate on a
map
and then the next data type a little bit
more complex
we moved into the
from nodes to ways
so away is actually just a collection of
nodes
and they have they come in three
different flavors so the first one is an
open way in an open way you can think of
it as just a line um and so these
include things like streets and rivers
and streams
and then we have two more different
types of ways and these are closed ways
and areas so a closed way is basically a
line but it um
it it starts where it stops right and so
these are things like roundabouts um
fall in this category um and then the
second thing we have are areas and so
these are what you would see on the map
is uh basically a polygon shape and
these include parks natural areas as
well as political boundaries
and as well as things like buildings too
and this would be a good kind of
um way a good point in the presentation
to interject this statistics is that
openstreetmap is actually the largest
database in the entire world of building
footprints so that's pretty cool um and
finally we have what's known as relation
and so relations basically provide a way
to arbitrarily nest and kind of relate
the first two types of data to each
other so with relations you can grow
group points nodes with each other you
can also group ways um but also too
some interesting kind of use cases
emerge so
anything any any polygon that is that
has a circle in it so for example a lake
with an island or a building footprint
that has a little courtyard in the
middle that's going to be relation
because it's a polygon and then a closed
way
and then
next thing you have are university
campuses
so think any sort of so a university
campus isn't necessarily just one
building but it's multiple buildings so
um in order to encapsulate that um we
use a relation and then the other thing
too is we're going to put bus routes
there and so these are open ways so
these are all like lines that are
grouped together to express a single
thing cool
and then finally
we've got all this great data but how do
we categorize it and how do we search
through it well openstreetmap has a
system of tagging and as hart is
basically just a simple key value store
and we can use this to categorize nodes
ways and relations
and from the openstreetmap wiki it says
you are free to create any tag you like
so it's supposed to be really really
versatile
anybody can submit stuff
that they want
but the thing is is that if you try to
go all willy-nilly and create whatever
you want you might run into some
you know because there's other people
that use it too and the community has
informal standards for this and so
if you're using a tag but there's
clearly a better alternative available
that more people are using then you're
going to be gently kind of pushed into
using it for that direction
but with that being said if you
are able to find a new tag and this
hasn't been used before and then all of
a sudden there's a big demand for it and
it and your tag kind of catches on and
people start using it well this is a way
for it to kind of informally um yeah
become a standard um the last thing i
want to mention about tags is that yes
it has this informal way of being
adopted and being adopted in the
community but there's also a formal
process to making changes with tags and
so anybody can go on the openstreetmap
wiki and they can submit a proposal and
then these proposals go through various
stages including votes and all that kind
of stuff before it's officially adopted
cool
and so here's some example tags so the
first one is called amenity
and amenity is really popular because it
includes all of kind of
things that are typically useful to
people or places that people want to go
so some example values here are going to
be cinema postbox town hall and lace
baskets because everybody needs waste
baskets
and then the second thing we have
is a is a tag called land use and land
use
might be more interesting to people
doing environmental research because
it's going to have values such as
commercial industrial residential but
it's also going to have things such as
farmland and forests and so you can do
some really interesting environmental
analysis
in openstreetmap with that tag alone
cool
all right so just explain all this data
sounds great how do i get my hands on it
well uh openstreetmap has a system of
mirrors available to see the fullest of
mirrors you can go to
openstreetmap.org
and they have basically a big list of of
a bunch of different types of mirrors um
my personal recommendation though is um
uh it's a mirror called geofabric and
they they make um they have the best
organized organization of this data um
basically when you go to the page you're
presented with a list of continents and
you can kind of drill down and go deeper
and deeper and deeper
it's really nice but the other thing too
is that sometimes this website is down
so
apparently these guys need some love
let's uh let's look and let's look at
supporting them because they actually
provide a really really great service so
yeah
really happy for them cool
and then
once you get the data and you download
it there's actually a specific type of
binary format that osm uses called the
pbf
and so this
before there are several other formats
such as xml you can actually even
download these files as shape files but
as far as community standards goes and
interoperability with all the different
tool sets out there this pbf format is
the recommended one and it's going to be
the fastest to process
all right
so now we've covered the basics of
openstreetmap data
how do we actually work with this in
postgresql
so before we do that what i want to do
is talk about what is what is actually
even geospatial and postgres anyway
right and so
like many things in the open source
community the post gis
plugin that i'm going to talk about was
kind of a confluence of a lot of good
ideas
so post gis
started back in about 2001 and one of
the key things that made postgis
possible
was
postgres's extension system
because
extensions were so easy to create the
initial post yes plugin was actually
written in under a month and just
included just basic geographic data
types
and so
they kept chugging along but the problem
was was that although they had these
awesome data types now for postgresql
they had no way to kind of perform any
sort of geospatial analysis and so this
is where projects like the open
geospatial consortium come in and also
another open source library called lib
gales and um
with the simple features for sql
standard defined and also too the the
libgios
basically it's a c plus plus library
providing all the algorithms for
implementing these kind of um geospatial
analysis and so when i say that these
are things like you know if you have a
polygon like how do you figure out how
many all the points inside this polygon
and so because of these two other
organizations and projects um these were
able to be easily at that and i kind of
incorporated into post gis and then
later on once they had that then we had
basically a full suite of geospatial
operations and post gis um the other
thing i want to mention too is that post
gis has adds the
spatial data types it has the spatial
processing functions and it also has um
basically spatial indexes as well
cool and so what do these data types
actually look like in postgresql
well we have a root geometry object and
then below that we have points line
strings and polygons
and then on the same level we have
something called a geometry collection
and below that we have multi-point
multi-line and multi-polygon
and so those are basically all the data
types there's some other geography stuff
too but i'm not going to get into that
in this presentation and so how do these
data types then map to the data types
that we just saw with openstreetmap
well luckily it's pretty simple it's
basically a one-to-one mapping so for
nodes that goes to a point open ways and
closed ways are represented as line
strings
areas are represented as polygons and
all these relations i'm talking about
can be represented as multi-polygon
multi-line stream
cool that's pretty simple and so now you
might be asking yourself well how do i
write a geospatial query
sorry we don't have enough time for that
but what i'm going to say to you because
that's basically a whole presentation in
itself what i'm going to say to you is
go to postgis.net
check out the introduction it's amazing
it's it's quite literally like a 30
chapter introduction and they work with
um the some u.s census data so it's
actually you're working with real data
learning how to run these post just
queries i would highly recommend
checking that out and again like i said
if you go to my website and go to my
blog you'll find a link there and on my
blog article i actually do
give a little bit of a rough intro to
writing spatial queries as well but
that's when the real fun starts
all right so now that we know kind of
okay
a little bit more about spatial types in
post gis and how it relates with osm now
we want to know how do we actually get
this data into our database
um so there's a
variety of tools out there and i'm going
to introduce two of them to you the
first one is a tool called osmium and
this is a command line tool with lots of
functions it's basically a swiss army
knife of osm data and with this tool you
can do diffs extracts merge and filters
all
using this pbf format that they have and
so what does an example command look
like
so this is an osmium command that uh
filters all of the um
it basically filters all the amenities
out of this large pbf file um this
germany latest and just to give you an
idea of how large this file is when you
download it the the the openstreetmap
data file for germany right now is about
3.6 gigabytes so it's a pretty large
file
cool um and so the second tool um that
you can use to get this stuff into um
postgresql is something called osm to pg
sql
and so this is a command line tool that
you can use to import osm data but it
also has two different modes of
operation including
creating and updating
and as of version 1.5 it supports
complex rules
via lewis scripts that we're going to
talk about a little bit later
and so here's what an example use of
this function looks like
so you just tell which database you want
the data to be imported to and then you
also give it a pdf file and then when
you import it
you're going to get this kind of list of
default tables and so it's going to be
line so this planet osm line planet osm
point and then planet osm polygon and
roads
and so this is really cool for if you
just want to kind of dig in and do some
exploratory data analysis and i
definitely recommend this at first
but as you kind of
start working on a project
the names of these tables aren't very
semantic they don't really tell you
what's in there it's just line point
polygons so it's not actually so it
might be really hard to categorize and
make your table schema nice which is
really important if you're going to
start any project with a database it's
always nice to have a really nice clean
looking database schema which isn't
always the case
as i've seen in many projects
but yeah so
how do we solve this problem well with
osm to pj pg sql
there is a
ability to have a flexible input and so
this is what i was talking about earlier
with the lewis scripts and so in order
to do this you basically specify output
flex and then you use the style flag to
point it to
your lua script
and then i'm going to show you an
example of what a lua script looks like
and actually a quick show of hands how
many people have ever done any
programming at all in lua
awesome that's cool so i i i think you
should know that but lua is a very it's
a really simple language a lot of times
you'll find it embedded into other
things i believe it's also available in
redis but don't hold me on that but yeah
so um yeah but let's get back to the the
the slide at hand so in order to define
your tables
you're going to create
a variable called tables
and then
below you just define what each one of
those tables is going to look like
and so the first one we'll define is an
amenity polygon
and then we give it the name here and
then what we do is we kind of map
some of the values to
[Music]
postgres values and so what we're going
to do is we're going to store the type
of amenity we're going gonna store all
the other tags associated with this
and actually that's a good
point to mention too so nodes ways and
relations they can have multiple tags so
they can be quite quite rich and quite
detailed feel
um yeah and so then finally what we'll
do is we're going to define a geometry
column there and then give a default
projection and then
and another thing i'll mention too is
when you're importing osm data um with
the tool by default it's using the 3857
which gives you um your coordinate
system in meters rather than degrees
like latitude and longitude which can be
actually a lot better at first you kind
of look at that data and you're saying
okay these huge numbers i don't know
what they mean but um it's really nice
when you can use meters because then you
can actually
more easily transfer it to kind of real
world
measurements such as kilometers so yeah
because the the conversion from meters
to kilometers is easier than degrees to
kilometers so cool and then below we're
going to define then a second table for
our points
and
doing basically the same thing and then
one thing i want to note too when you
use the flex output
you can't store
points and polygons beside each other
they have to kind of go to their own
separate tables so cool
all right and then
so and usually in the upper part you're
going to kind of define what you want
your tables to look like and then below
you have these kind of hook functions
where you can
basically just define what you want when
you're going to be importing something
so here i've defined a hook function for
processing a node
and it does a really simple thing it's
just going to say hey if this object's
tags amenities thing is is not null then
we want you to go ahead and import it
but because you can use if statements
here i mean these can get as complicated
as you'd like
yeah and i'm going to link later to a
really great git repo where someone's
built a lot of really amazing um little
examples that you can use
so you don't have to start from zero if
you don't want to write that much lua
cool and so then when you um
after you've basically done this import
we can see that our table schema looks a
bit better now now we have um all of our
data organized by the type of data that
they are so we have amenity points and
many polygons
oh
all right and so now we're getting into
the best part of the talk because it's
the python part of the talk very cool so
organizing your projects with python how
how do we even like go about doing
something like that well
let's go ahead and organize this as if
we're completing a task so you've just
been given a task
and
you won a contract
um you've bid you've bid there are all
kinds of bidders but you've eventually
won this contract and it's a lucrative
contract too you're getting millions of
dollars for this so this is or millions
of euros it's going to be really cool
and it's a contract with trash cans
united they're a trashcan advocacy group
and they want to do trash can research
in germany
and you're going to be their eyes and
ears on the ground
so for this project what they require is
they want to know
the statistics for all the trash cans
and the 10 largest cities in germany
um and they will also want to know like
what's the number of trash cans over
time you know they they're probably
going to want to come back to you
every year and and you're thinking to
this you're to yourself you're saying
wow this is great this is a contract
that i'm going to be able to get money
for every year awesome and then um and
then the other thing they want to do is
they say
yeah well travis you know at first we're
going to want trash can info for the top
it's you know 10 cities but you know
over time this could grow and we maybe
would maybe we even build a trash can
dashboard on our website this and so all
these things and your mouth's getting
wet at this point because you're like oh
i mean you just see dollar signs in your
eyes because you're really ready to work
on this and and for some reason now you
love trash cans so
let's get into it um
but before we get started with this
right let's let's see what this data
pipeline kind of looks like um and so
for this data pipeline specifically
we're going to want to initially get um
some data from gale fabrique and then
we're going to store that in
an initial pdf file and then afterwards
what we'll do is we're going to extract
all the cities that we care about so the
top 10 um in germany and then we're
going to basically write that to a
our own kind of project data file and
then and at the end we're going to want
to import it into a postgres database
and then from there we can write all the
kind of reports that we're going to need
and
output this as diagrams and then send it
to trash cans united
cool
but the
the thing is though is that
i i just i don't know how i'm going to
go about
organizing this i i think maybe why i
could write a web application but yeah
that seems a little overkill you know
it's
i don't even i don't know if i want to
go there yet and then so you're thinking
ah like how how could i possibly do it
you what's that obi-wan use the use the
cli yeah
that makes sense because
what did we just see we just saw two
awesome
you know cli programs osmium and osm to
pg sql why not write our own and throw
that in the mix that sounds like a great
idea
but
and i hope this doesn't describe any of
you here but maybe some of you hear the
word cli and you think
you think this right no
okay let me let me let me go ahead and
just kind of assuade your concerns right
uh why are clies great
all right so why is writing a cli good
idea so this enables kind of rapid
development fast feedback cycles right
so you're writing it and you could test
it write it run it write it run it and
when you're doing that it's really
important because then you can kind of
see your changes over time and just have
a really a really fast feedback cycle so
that you can develop quite quickly
um the other thing too is that these
tools can be integrated with other tools
right they're composable so the other
tools we just saw osmium and osmpg sql
they can be included as part of like of
a data pipeline like we just saw
and then the other thing too is that um
recently and i'm sure a lot of you know
this but the but the cli library out
there the ecosystem for python is
amazing and it's also amazing across a
bunch of other libraries
so my personal favorites in this realm
are
click and rich they make i mean click is
great because it can help you structure
your cli programs and rich can help make
them beautiful so there's a lot of
really good tools out there and yeah
that's that's how we're going to do it
and so
our cli program is going to be called in
kind of the osm spirit everything should
begin all cli tools should begin with
osm so it's going to be called osm proj
which stands for osm project management
and then um specifically what we're
going to do is we're going to have a
an initial command called osm proj
preparer so this is going to do the
downloading and extraction process and
then we're going to have osm report and
that's going to do our reporting process
and the cool thing is because osm to pg
sql is already such an amazing kind of
tool it's going to handle the importing
for us so really excited about that
and so when we write the program well
what is the actual like file structure
layout look like
so this is just one example um and this
is my personal preference for how i like
to do this stuff but um we're going to
have a kind of top level folder called
osm proj and then below that
we're going to have a folder called
commands and so whenever i'm writing
kind of command line tools that have
these kind of sub commands here like
prepare and report i'm always going to
basically dedicate separate files to
them it makes the project really easy
nice and orally and you're able to find
everything quite quickly
and then we move further down basically
we're going to have this cli so this is
going to be where the entry point to our
cli program lives
and then finally
i'm going to have separate modules for
doing things with databases and separate
modules for doing things with http um so
i like to organize my modules in terms
of services um so for example if you go
to the the repository website you're
going to also see other things such as
report or chart or cache so every kind
of new service has its own separate
module
and then finally um i'm
for packaging and doing everything i'm
using poetry right now and so that's
going to all live all that config is
going to live in a pi um project um
tamil and then finally every good
project needs an even better read me so
always include that read me
cool and so now we're going to get into
the kind of nitty gritty of like what
these commands actually look like so for
osm prepare um
we're going to basically
excuse me it's going to be
a command that accepts a config and
inside this config is going to be all
the cities that we want to extract and
then
this
second argument here is this europe
germany and this kind of roughly maps to
the way these things are kind of passed
on on geofabric so that's going to
enable us to download store that quite
easily and then finally we're going to
have an output file so it's going to be
our project.data and so inside of this
config file is
going to live it's a json file it's
going to hold the extracts and this is
also the same format that the osmium
tool accepts
and also i should mention right now that
underneath the covers prepare is
actually calling
basically two osmium commands we're
calling extract and merge
so we're basically downloading
everything and then we extract all the
cities that we want and at the very end
we merge everything in together to get
that project data and also too and and
then the really cool thing is that you
can write these python programs um and
use subprocess and in my opinion
writing a python program like this is um
much better than writing a bash script
so yeah that's just my personal opinion
and i think maybe some of you would
agree cool
all right and so now let's get uh talk
about like okay what does the reporting
look like
and so for the reporting we're going to
have a couple different things going on
so first we want to define the top
cities and we'll define that as a like a
shell cell variable but really what
we're doing is just passing it in later
as an argument but this is a nice little
shorthand to do that um
and then uh we have the same config and
in this config we're going to hold
things like a database connection so we
don't have to pass in everything on the
command line so that's another nice
thing to do and then this is kind of the
meat and potatoes of this specific
report so the reports are going to hold
these kind of sub reports and the this
is called amenity city and then
it accepts two different types of
arguments it's going to accept the
city's argument and then also the
amenity that you want to measure and for
us it's going to be wastebasket because
we're doing trashcan research
and then finally
we have an output type right and so this
output type is going to be a chart and
then what this does is it's going to use
the plotly library to write us a nice
looking html chart
but the cool thing is and i'll talk
about this later is that with this
output type right you can you can throw
anything you wanted it right you can do
a terminal output um if it's going to be
used for a web map you can do a geo json
output
so this is really cool and when you kind
of start thinking about your programs
like this right you can start thinking
modularly right and and and how you want
to extend it and so when you want to add
a new output type there it's as easy as
just adding a new type so cool
oh yeah actually wait i i hope no one
saw that so actually before i show that
next graph
does anyone who thinks
and maybe everyone saw it but who thinks
is the city with the most trash cans in
germany
yeah anyone know okay
i'll i'll go ahead and show you but
basically um the number one city in
germany is stuttgart
closely followed by mission and then
berlin and then coal and also to let you
know that this is the amenity per square
kilometer so
this is kind of an imperfect measurement
right but it's yeah so basically
stuttgart has 11.93 basically 12 trash
cans per square kilometer um so that's
how you can read that
and yeah it's it's it's fun um this was
just kind of thrown together quite
quickly um moving on and getting an
actual like better analysis here i think
uh that you would want to bring in
population density um that would be
another good thing to do um yeah but
this is just super super simple and this
is actually so population density i have
to bring another data set but this is
just using all the data that's available
in openstreetmaps and then um like i
said before
when you can utilize different outputs
and especially using something like rich
you can generate these like nice
beautiful tables on the terminal
so that's really cool and then you can
yeah add more data right so the actual
number um so if we looked at like total
numbers um berlin wins by far it's got
7489
trash cans
which is a lot but it's also the biggest
city but the other thing too is um when
we're looking at this data as well right
um this is a good point to mention this
about kind of osm data is that
it just because
you know what you see here
you have to remember because it's
community and contributed data so if we
look at leipzig okay we could say yo man
there's barely any trashcans in leipzig
you know they only have like two per
square kilometers but the thing is is
maybe they haven't been tracking them as
well as stuttgart so
just remember when you when you go
digging into osm you need to also be
verifying by either doing like kind of
using institute measurements where
you're um
basically looking on the ground or
verifying it with another data set or
even trying to
see okay
who is actually contributing the data
like the trashcan data
and all that
you should be able to do on their
website where you can actually see who
contributed to that and if you go to
openstreetmap.org you can click on
individual features and see who the
actual contributor was so yep
cool and so um
yeah one of the last things i wanted to
talk about was kind of sharing your work
with others
and this is where
writing clis and
kind of thinking in this way can really
help when you want others to either help
out or extend the project that you've
done
so i highly encourage people to
from the outset right think about how
they're going to package and share
their work with others and one of the
one of the really great ways is to use a
kind of a like a
tool like poetry in order to help you
build python packages and put them on
pipi
if you'd like to make it public and open
source
but even if you wouldn't if you don't
want to make it public or open source
and just have it be private um tools
like this can be really really useful um
for getting people started yeah um
and
let's see
so
yeah and then i i guess the so this is
one of the last slides i want to show
and this is why you would use this
method and so
like our project requirements said
earlier
is that they they gave us initial
specifications
but they
they they kind of had this like mvp
right the minimum viable product they
wanted but then um what they wanted to
do is scale up maybe add new reports
maybe add different kinds of reports add
new cities um so this method would be
great if you're dealing with adapting
kind of project specifications right you
you want to i mean that's the whole idea
about good software design is that you
build software to be flexible to
changing kind of circumstances and
that's a really really cool way
to kind of build your analysis projects
too
um the other thing is that you can use
this method if you want to run this
repeatedly so you're going to need to
run this on a server or in a docker
container or maybe in some sort of like
github action or something like that
right you want to have like kind of
robots do this for you
but the cool thing is when you write
clies right clis are friendly to robots
but they're also friendly to humans too
which is cool
and like i said before it helps you to
kind of share your code
and then furthermore and this is the
last point i'll talk about is
when you write programs in this way it
can kind of help instill
you know best practices in software
design
so for me personally when i first
started my analysis project last year um
it was
initially done using kind of jupiter lab
and jupiter notebooks and while this was
really great for exploratory data
analysis and i still
and if i'm just kind of want a proof of
concept just kind of do something really
quick i'll go to that
but
i also had the problem where the jupiter
notebooks eventually got so big that i
just kind of i was super confused by
them and they don't have all the nice
things that you get from an ide right
like code linting
and those kinds of things so
what i what i now in my workflow is what
i try to do is that yeah jupiter
notebook's an amazing place just to kind
of sketch things out but as soon as i
have a really clear idea of what i want
the project to be i jump right back into
an ide and i start planning my projects
in this way so but that's my own
personal experience um and i know
there's going to be some great talks on
jupiter and i'm i'm actually really
looking forward to them too so
cool cool
i'm not i'm not trying to dog on jupiter
but it's just for my personal workflow
that's usually what i'm doing
exploratory data analysis there and then
when i have everything kind of cemented
i'm moving to an ide
to really uh plan everything out
all right and so these are the resources
that you can go check out um so
like i said my blog site's going to have
them there
but then there's also some further
resources um available below um and then
yeah i think i briefly mentioned it but
really this um
it's uh this pg osm project pgos and
flex has tons and tons of like great loo
examples their whole idea is that they
really want to
kind of create an analysis-ready
database so even more so than these lua
like scripts they also have like a
docker image that you can use to kind of
quickly just
get a database and begin connecting to
it and doing analysis so i really would
recommend checking that project out and
then like i said before
the introduction to post gis
is really great too and then further and
the other thing too
is this tag info
website that i may have briefly
mentioned but tag info is cool because
you can look at all the different tags
in openstreetmap but then you can see
how many are used and so you can start
to get an idea okay how popular is this
tag and how how widespread is its use
so cool and i believe
that does it so thank everybody for
listening to my talk
[Applause]
so thanks
travis
for this interesting talk and
unfortunately
given the delay on the opening session
we do
have a time for the questions but you
can
ask your question directly to travis
setting here in the conference after
the talk and
thanks for being here and enjoyed the
next
talk in the conference
thank you everybody